stop more about our main story the
broadcaster ITV saying that now is the
right time for the Jeremy Kyle show to
end the talk show which has run for 14
years was permanently cancelled earlier
today following the death of a
participant MPs on the Commons media and
culture committee have announced an
inquiry into reality television as a
result comedian in broadcaster teri
Christian joins us now from Manchester
Terry thanks very much saying the time
to speak to us this evening you've made
your feelings clear on on the programme
on your social media channels what was
it about the show that you disliked so
thoroughly well I mean I come from a
strongly working-class background you
know I grew up on benefits I actually
work the Jeremy you know for two years
you know on radio so we used to cross
over and I got on work well with him
except for on the school of politics and
the reality is you know 14 years they
should have taken that show off 14 years
ago it's disgraceful it's fair behen
that's all it's ever been it's and it's
a it's attacking poor people I mean what
I said on social media is basically
would they employ me to get Boris
Johnson on and shout to him and say what
about your mistresses who paid for them
what about you being sacked for for
lying twice no but when it comes to poor
people with problems it's almost like
you are the authors of your own
misfortune so I'm allowed to speak to
you any way that I like and it and it
didn't help the fact that Jeremy is a
public school boy so he's shouting up
people whose lives he's got no entry no
kind of if you like experience of
there's nothing visceral to him about it
and so the whole portrayal of it was
bear baiting and it was Oakley I mean I
did watch a few of them you know because
I could understand why I was popular but
I felt like I needed to take a shower
now that isn't Jeremy kales fault
that's ITV's fault you've got to look at
who runs the media and allows these
shows because all they're going to do
with this they love being poor people
benefit stream the bailiffs are coming
all those kind of shows it's all about
demonizing poor people demonizing people
who grew up on council estates you know
I'm no bleeding heart MIT liberal but
you don't have to be intelligent to see
it you know what about why don't we do
tax dodge it's ours you know I find out
it's
we could have bought three hospitals of
the morning you didn't pay in taxes last
year you know there's plenty of
dysfunctional rich people in this
country in fact all our problems are
caused by them hiyee brexit the tax
dodgers cha so so this this this point
for you terry is is a class issue at its
root
absolutely well what you mean it but is
if i am the only one who sees it of
course it's a class issue in the 2010
equality is act they should have made
socio-economic class one of the things
in it because that is the one that is
the major one not race because it
whatever race you are you've got a
socio-economic class and most black
people and people from ethnic minorities
in this country a working class so they
get it doubled its well the big one is
socio-economic class we live in a feudal
system we've got the biggest divide of
of rich and poor in the EU you know
these are all our problems it's not the
e used problems and they're not jeremy
Kyle's problems but you've got to ask
why is a national broadcaster putting
programs like this out I mean never mind
that somebody has to kill themselves
before they go oh maybe that's wrong to
have people there who are obviously
obviously poor through no fault of their
own because I have not very bright
they've got men mountain it mental
illness or they haven't got word and go
well I haven't you got a job cook would
I be allowed to sit on a step we Prince
Andrew and say why are you were a kid
okay this house just important to
mention it is they're reportedly at this
Manor took his own life we're just
waiting of course for it for
confirmation on the details on that is
important for us to say that and as a
broadcaster
well you but when you talk about people
watching it Terry
a hundred sorry not a hundred a million
people I think roughly a day watch this
what does it tell us about us as viewers
well it's the same in the old days you
still had to pay to go around bedlam and
look at them up people Finlay you know
people used to love a public hanging
swim should we cater for that is that
what our society is about on what's
worse is it then demonizes the poor so
it allows the government to sanction
people the DWP to persecute people for
being poor to make it be their fault and
that's what it's all about when you
watch the Jeremy Kyle show that's what
it was all about he was attacking people
for being poor or for not being able to
work off of being drug addicts come on
you know it's not their fault so in some
cases it might be but that isn't the job
of a broadcaster report the news talk to
those people about the lives don't
berate them for being poor wiring your
put something on the end of it mate you
know I've attended yeah that was and
that indeed was something that was said
during a program I was looking at it
earlier Terry bobbies looked reading an
interview with you from a couple of
years back in the New Statesman and your
program that you presented the word and
it's important to point out you said
that you thought this was exploitation
at the time the hopeful segment on that
program people members of the general
public wait for trench coat of
french-kissing pensioners drinking their
own vomit the things like that I know
you and I know it's important to say
that you in that interview saying wait
wait Tom Tom Tom Tom we never had any
pensioners this article says people
kissing pensioners and then drinking
their own vomit
but but hold on hold on student pranks
and I hated that strand anyway I said I
said there needs to be you youthful that
was exploitation you didn't listen you
didn't like I just wondering that I'm
just wondering you yeah when that
happened that choice do you do you think
looking back at the 90s that that that
was the start of this kind of this kind
of programming at all I think back on
our show what I didn't like about that
at the time was a thought was a gimmick
it was contrivance but it was student
pranks it was their choice they knew
what they were doing they weren't really
kill for it people are laughing with
them not at them but what I hated about
the snare Innes of it was
99% of the people who made the word were
X public-school let's laugh at the
peasants it's that kind of thing
they don't say all publicly they say it
privately I've been I was in the
meetings you know what you know some
some medical student doing something
horrendous like drinking a pint of his
own vomit or somebody else you know
eating a worm sandwich that's up to them
to me it wasn't entertainment we never
needed it and in fact that's what God's
taken off the air and maybe it's a
rightly so but but what it is is as TV
is dumbed down as it's cheap and we've
got more and more of this and if you
take you know Jeremy's show for instance
you know Jeremy's or it's almost like
one slogan after another it's like like
our politics isn't it he has his certain
catchphrase is every now and then
they'll let one go I'll say may we're
here to help you and turn the fake
concern dial up to 11 now these programs
will continue on TV they'll carry on
making them what what they'll do is and
probably stick some nice psychologist in
next to them you know to turn the fake
dial up to 11 and make out the caring
when really all they're after is
exploiting people and our main misery
and soft and on that note do you do you
think I mean you say there's they'll
continue do you think there is a place
for them at all with regard to this
inquiry that's going to go on is there a
future as a sir is this a turning point
in this particular type of program well
I I hope it's a turning point and the
problem is Leslie forget about what's
happened with Jeremy Carol at the moment
why have ITV been showing this for 14
years phase to make things like Weald in
action phase to make things worth
watching let's have a look at the
socio-economic background and the people
making these shows an important show to
me never mind benefit Street turn that
camera 180 degrees around and make a
documentary about the people who make
those shows then you'll find something
socially very interesting Terry listen
thanks for taking the time to speak to
us appreciate it this evening
brilliant